you look like you're a wrestler I
wrestled it played football in high
school do you take Holly are you pitting
me against Paulie right now well Paul II
will do this occasionally where he'll
pit himself against him he took on it
feels like yeah did you ask me if you
called me for the NCAA champ I'm called
a finite he'll take on a four-time NCAA
champ only wrestled him how do you do
and you Duplin all I got in in 12 SEC
okay Super Bowl week he loves to rumble
of all he just took off his glasses case
in case you just and do we take her mics
off first and then we go no microphone
is on you want a piece you can do it
right now these reviews there's money I
mean this segment we have a good
relationship
oh I know this is friendly way of
acknowledging you're probably you seem
more like a steady face I'm here are we
doing this now yeah you go ahead all
right now this is you guys just okay
here we go
you feel like I'm in man shake yeah
we're doing these he's got some strong
for us go it yeah we're doing it okay
all right okay ready ready okay here we
go
[Laughter]
Casey man versus food and I said case
you look like you were a wrestler he
goes a wrestler and football player in
high school
Paulie takes his glasses off stands up
in it's go time
Casey grabbed him slammed him down now
Paulie
we're on the eighth floor of this
condominium that we're in with our
mancave I'm gonna guess on the first
floor you probably heard Paulie thumping
as Casey went to the floor
paulie's got a flask here and he's gonna
take a little sip there case welcome to
the show that's quite an entrance
thereby ruin our relationship
Paulie all right that's one of the
stronger dudes we've had in here Jay
Mohr was strong Caltech restore Casey's
like a wombat he just attacked me I mean
you know for me it's when you when
you're told to perform you know you know
play slapbox you know you didn't realize
Paulie took his glasses off and then he
stood up and he wanted a piece of you go
are we really gonna do this I said yes
and then you grabbed him and then threw
him to the floor he also kind of snug me
up like a boa constrictor around a
little you know like a little animal
just wanted to squeeze the air Adi is
it's an all-new man versus food on
Travel Channel cheese spicy night newest
mission is face to face with jumbo
chicken tenders smothered in a Carolina
Reaper infused sauce that was in
Nashville yeah that was let's get to air
but that's coming up okay and then in
Boise its sushi and soup challenge so
it's daya it's so diabolically hot it
goes by the name of demons delight it's
man vs. food only on Travel Channel
are there ever times you just tap out
with something they put in front of me
you just say yeah kind like Paulie when
you know you're on your diet but they
you have to pre-approve before you do it
right there's no surprises on there's no
surprises for me it's not really until I
build the thing on camera that I really
know what it looks like because pictures
never really tell you what's happening
you know like when we do the we're
looking at what we're gonna be
challenging now yesterday you created a
challenge for the danos now we don't
want to give away results now we're
gonna show some of the highlights of
this the rest of the week oh great so
give give the audience an idea of what
each Danette was trying to challenge to
tackle yesterday so the Dan Nets want to
take on a very big challenge and for the
last few weeks I've been giving them
some advice on how to take on whether it
be spicy because they didn't know what
they're gonna take on you could have
been spicier could have been larger food
for a larger consumption so yeah I gave
him some advice and we had like how big
was the burger there were cheese curds
and onion fries in hot dogs it was
10,000 calories and about 6 pounds of
food and then I walk in and Seaton and
McLovin have milkshakes to go now was
that good strategy that was not good
strategy when these guys yeah see if
somebody's gonna throw a mint chocolate
chip shake in front of you you drink it
mmm did ordered though see Polly Polly
had a beer in front of him and then
they're all done with the challenge and
they go what what what do we do in case
he goes just hold hands and go walk go
take a nice walk and like good employees
they just started walking down the
street hand in hand I don't know if that
bad walk helped you guys but you guys
were in trouble a little bit there yeah
Paul Casey did give us some great tips
before like going protein first before
the breads stretching out standing up
like and these things really worked you
definitely have to stretch eating the
proteins first getting because the carbs
will kill you right how the carbs do for
you guys rough right yeah they were
tough now how would you do against these
like the Nathan hot-dog-eating guys see
you know coming into this I was very
much of an underdog you know very much
like our two teams that are about to
play in the Super Bowl you know I
I don't know it's good question because
I wasn't a professional leader before I
started doing it are you a professional
leader now some might say that yeah I
know you get paid to do it but if there
was competitive eating how would you see
very much just like what Paulie and I
just went through I was called to arms
so i armed myself and that's you know
we're postseason too and I've just been
you know doing my best to get through
these challenges with with a lot of
vigor man vs. food Monday night's 9:00
Eastern on Travel Channel the special
episode Ozarks what happens in the
Ozarks because there's a show that I
watch called Ozark and love it there's
some bad things that happen there what
happens in the Ozarks case usually it
stays there but in this particular
episode which airs tonight
Kirby's cupcakes in Rogers Arkansas
which is in the middle of the Ozarks
mm-hmm
I take on a cupcake the size of 22
cupcakes so that was kind of like a face
first thing you know you just there's
nothing other than a cupcake in front of
you so I'm top to bottom top to bottom
and you just we all have to tune in to
see what the results were but when you
walk into a restaurant what happens when
they recognize you what what do the
restaurant owners want to give you well
oftentimes I'm wearing a hat I'm in
disguise well you know as a result of
the show I've become more noticeable so
I've tried to hide a little bit I take
the hat off the big fire red hair I get
noticed more so but usually they're
pretty good people don't no one asked me
to do anything crazy or order something
crazy off the menu Oh cuz I would bring
something over and say let me see if you
could write this you would yeah but they
don't people are pretty polite about it
you know so I mean I'm looking forward
to something happening you know like
what you know the people are pretty
respectful about that they realize
that's the show and it's not every day
that I can you know I didn't prepare to
come out to dinner any you know your
giant lobster bisque soup you know any
any meal bring you to tears most of them
like do you most like you just go I
honestly watching the guys yesterday
kind of little tear in my eyes
that what they did could you have done
more damage than what the dance did with
that meal yesterday to say I mean
McLovin kind of crushed it you know he
did well but we don't know I mean fritzy
did well - he did really well yeah yeah
not giving anything away
no Olly yeah Olly well competitive all
very competitive yeah see I would have
sat down with him if I've known would
have known but you know I was in a
coaching position so that was very
exciting for me that's where the tier
key oh yeah these guys geared up though
thank because we were gonna have lunch
and I said you guys are crazy and I
walked in and all of a sudden I had some
sad dance there it was weeks of
preparation I know yeah Seton was still
is no it's just something about when
you're going through this food and
you've eaten so much already and then
you like flip something over and there's
like a burger hidden under a grilled
cheese sandwich that you still have to
do in your life
you were lifting up stuff holy would
like a rematch right now if you can
because actually that's incorrect day oh
I thought you wanted a rematch there
were like 30 seconds here that's all
Casey needs to piñas he went spider
monkey on me I'm done I'm tapping he's
Casey Webb it's man versus food a Monday
nights 9:00 Eastern and tonight it's the
Ozarks as Casey travels to the Ozarks to
tackle the Goliath a massive cupcake
that equals 20 to regular-size cupcakes
what could go wrong well you didn't die
because you're here it's still here yeah
case thank you we love seeing you and I
love the support with man versus food
and travel channel for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
[Music]